when you think of elite and exclusive
restaurants you typically do not think
of airport dining but hidden inside
Newark Liberty International Airport is
one of the trendiest and hard to get
into restaurants United Airlines teamed
up with the Hospitality Group OTG to
create the classified dining experience
and Kris Van Cleave scored an invitation
to show us around good morning the
people walking through terminal C here
at Newark Airport have no idea they're
walking right by one of the most
sought-after restaurants in all of the
New York area we can't show you where it
is because it's hidden on purpose but we
will be able to take you inside through
this door and down this secret hallway a
speakeasy meets fine dining it's
classified
here your taste buds will delight if you
can score and invite the invite only
restaurant has just 36 seats and is just
steps from your gate it's exclusive
guest list boasts CEOs and celebrities
like Madonna it's very much like in New
York it's you know secret I actually had
to take a little bit of time to find it
and the hostess was very discreet so I
felt very special United frequent-flyer
Bree Morrow was one of the first invited
to make a reservation I just had a stirs
and I'm eating a very fresh salad with
shrimp
so I appreciate being able to have a
healthy meal with a nice glass of wine
the menu and wine list rivals anything
you'd see at a trendy New York City
restaurant and can easily set you back a
hundred dollars a person that's if you
don't order a 500 plus dollar bottle of
wine it's an oasis inside a restaurant
inside an airport James Beard
award-winning chef Nate Appleman is the
VP of culinary for OTG the restaurant
company that teamed with United Airlines
to turn this mostly forgotten meeting
room into classified
we talked with Nate as he prepared a 42
ounce tomahawk steak one of their
signature dishes most airports have
prepackaged food that's been cooked
before and somebody's just heating it in
a microwave here we're actually cooking
from scratch we're using great product
and you can't find that anywhere it is
an unusual business plan to create a
restaurant that people don't know where
it is and have to be invited into well
isn't that a lot of fun even just saying
that Ric blackstein is OTG CEO we wanted
to create a really unique space that's
kind of out of the way a little bit of a
speak easiest way to get to but
somewhere where you can just enjoy a
great meal listen to some nice music
have a delicious glass of wine take it
easy to get yourself away from
everything else people don't think of
Newark Airport as a spot for trendy
dining they don't but they soon will
we're it hopefully as a united vice
president the airline looks at
classified as a way to surprise and
delight but just who gets invited well
there's not just one perspective or one
way we look at the invitation list but
right now it is classified and it does
remain a secret was the idea to create
one of the elite restaurants in New York
here in the Newark Airport we didn't set
out to make the most elite restaurant
and most difficult to get into but it
kind of worked out that way so this is
your ticket inside the email invitation
United says for the Flyers who haven't
gotten one yet they can request to be
invited to classified but they won't say
how long the wait list is our Kris Van
Cleave there I have not gotten I just
checked my email invitation so my big
pet peeve with restaurants at airports
is that they don't have bathrooms inside
the rescuers that's my watch I can watch
it like you have to go out to the actual
airport to go to the bathroom because
they don't if if classified has one then
you'll love it but the thing I would
hope that they at least help you get
through security I mean you already have
a lot of time spent at the airport it'd
be good if that reservation right invite
came with a little help yes although as
a frequent traveler anything that sort
of ups the game is certainly a pre-baked
look good